um so Dr fauci uh you're preparing to
step away from NIH and I'm just
wondering how you're sort of feeling in
these final weeks
well it's a Bittersweet feeling because
I have been at the National Institutes
of Health
for now 54 years and I have been the
director of the National Institute of
allergy and infectious diseases for the
last 38 years
so I feel good about an enthusiastic
about what I would consider the next
phase in a very long career
uh but it is very uh poignant and
and emotional uh to realize that
54 years ago
I came to this institution this campus
here in Bethesda Maryland
uh driving down from New York City as
the newly minted
physician who had just finished his
residency training in a New York City
Hospital to come down for an infectious
diseases Fellowship
really not knowing what was ahead uh
really being in many respects plurry
potential and not knowing what direction
I was going to go and I've really had
the the privilege of having had the
opportunity
to get involved in some things that I
feel very good about over the course of
my career
but I do feel an enthusiasm
about asking myself which I have done at
my age since I've been here for 54 years
I came as a 27 year old newly minted
physician and I'm now a soon to be 82
year old senior person in the biomedical
research and and Global Health
establishments so I ask myself
what do I have to offer the country in
the world
because I've been in public service my
entire professional life and I want to
stay in public service even though
I'm not going to be in the in the
auspices and Under the Umbrella of the
federal government
and I think one of the things I want to
do is I want to be able to to use the
benefit of my multi-multi-decade
experience
to perhaps help others in an advisory
capacity to write to lecture and to
maybe and hopefully inspire
younger people who are in science or
those who are considering going into
science and Public Health
what a wonderful field that is
particularly if it's done in the arena
of Public Service
yeah I have to ask as you look back on
all those decades uh in public service
is there a favorite moment a favorite
memory a favorite accomplishment that
really stands out to you
you know I'd have to say there isn't a
favorite because I have had the
privilege
of of of over such an extended period of
time of wearing multiple hats the hats
of a scientist prior to HIV
the head of a scientist with the
emergence of HIV
the Hat of an Institute director of a
very very large
biomedical research institution here at
the NIH
and as the Hat of someone who's gotten
involved in policy where I've had the
privilege of advising seven presidents
of the United States starting
with Ronald Reagan and in each of those
buckets of my life as it were
there is one of two things that I feel
pretty good about I mean prior to HIV I
was involved in a very Niche kind of
area of
biomedical research and looking for
therapies for formally fatal
inflammatory diseases that are unusual
if not rare not very many people heard
about it but they were deadly diseases
and I had the opportunity to develop
therapies that had a 95 percent
remission in other
wise fatal diseases so I felt very good
about that element of research even
though it was very well confined
and not very many people were aware of
it which is fine that's not the reason
to do it
um then when HIV came along I have for
the last 40 plus years had that be my
focus of my own personal research
and I've had the opportunity to
delineate
what we call some of the pathogenic
mechanisms of HIV disease and by no
means that I do that alone there were so
many good people throughout the country
in the world who've contributed to that
but it is recognized that I've played an
important role in that so I feel good
about that
then the next hat was as director of the
National Institute of allergy and
infectious diseases and the thing that I
feel good about that a high point is
that I
established a separate division to focus
predominantly on HIV AIDS at a time
when the world did not have much of
interest in HIV AIDS even though it was
insidiously creeping through the world
killing a lot of people
and the and the group that I put
together the division of AIDS by
granting and Contracting with a lot of
talented investigators throughout the
country and the world and partnering
with the pharmaceutical companies we
were able to be part of the process
that put together the combinations of
drugs that have literally saved millions
of lives throughout the world
and really converted HIV disease
from an otherwise fatal disease
to a chronic condition that people could
live essentially normal lives
and then the other one was my
opportunity to interact with seven
presidents of the United States and one
stands out in particular
when President George W bush
gave me the opportunity
because of his vision to try and make
sure that people who live in areas of
the world that don't have resources
that have a lot of HIV that they won't
die because of lack of ability to get
proper drugs and treatment and and
prevention so he tasked me and I very
gladly accepted the task
of being one of the principal architects
of the president's emergency plan for
AIDS relief or pepfar
which has actually resulted in the
saving of anywhere from 18 to 20 million
lives worldwide that's probably the
thing that I feel most
uh a good about in the sense of having
had the privilege of being able to be
part of that and then the last three
years you know very well about is that
we've had the opportunity of being part
of our response to covid-19 particularly
my responsibility was the scientific
part of it which was a great success
because again in collaboration with
pharmaceutical companies and utilizating
utilizing
the talents and the vision of a lot of
good scientists throughout the country
in the world
to put together a vaccine in an
absolutely unprecedented record time of
11 months
from the time that the virus was
recognized in January of 2020
to the time that 11 months later we had
a vaccine that was safe and highly
effective in essentially saving billions
of lives so when you have a career as
long as I had there were multiple
components of that Each of which has a
little bit of a Twist to us and I just
feel that I've been extremely fortunate
to have had the opportunity
to participate in some of the things
that we've just discussed
yeah you know I wanted to ask you as
well because you know you've been in the
public eye through all of this right
you've been in the public eye through
your work with HIV right through to your
work with covid
and I'm sort of curious what you've seen
in the changes in public discourse and
the challenges around communicating
issues of Public Health uh to Everyday
People
well there are a number of challenges
but the one that is the most uh pressing
right now and in many respects
the most disturbing
is the anti-science attitude
uh among some which is associated for
example specifically with an anti-vaxx
movement when we know that vaccines are
a life-saving and safe
but importantly the politization of
science
where in the United States you have the
adherence or not
to very clear Public Health principles
that are influenced strongly by one's
ideology
where you should have a uniform approach
towards an acceptance of things that are
proven to be life-saving and yet you
have the uptake of vaccines and the
performance of
of uh activities
that are aimed at preventing the spread
and the effect of infection and you have
major differences in the country
based on ideology an example of that is
if you look at Red States versus blue
States or republican conservative
dominated States versus
moderate or more Progressive
uh states that are blue States
you find that the degree of uptake of
vaccine
is much much less among the red States
and that results quite frankly and the
data were clear
in more hospitalizations and deaths in
those areas of the country that should
never be a person should not suffer and
die
because certain ideologies tell them
that they should or should not accept
the vaccine it doesn't matter what your
political ideology is
when you have a life-saving intervention
you should utilize that life-saving
intervention not only for yourself
but for your family and your community
does that make you worry about what the
response to the next public health
emergency or next pandemic could look
like
well if we have the degree of political
divisiveness in our country
with the next pandemic I'm afraid that
the response in many respects could even
be worse in some areas than it was we
had a very good scientific preparedness
and response but not such a very good
Public Health response even though we
thought we were really very well
prepared My Hope Is
that we learn the lessons of the things
that we could have done better
during this outbreak and I hope one of
the lessons is the obvious nature
and the obvious uh realization
that political divisiveness is not
helpful
when you're dealing with a common enemy
that's the virus and when we learn that
the enemy is the virus not each other
then let's get together all of us and
work as as as one unified approach
towards essentially combating a thing
that's killing us no matter whether we
are of one political ideology or another
I know that uh you and your family have
have sort of paid a terrible price for
the the amount of polarization around
the coveted response uh would you have
ever expected that as a scientist that
you would have been sort of the central
public figure and face of the
polarization around a a public health
emergency
no the answer was no obviously not in my
wildest dreams would I have thought
that an issue
that that I chose as my profession which
is
saving the lives and protecting people
against illness which is what I've done
ever since I entered medical school
um that that would be a reason for
people
to have uh
extraordinary hostility
towards people in my field with the
personification because I'm a very
visible person that I have become you
know the boogeyman as it were
of the radical elements in our society
which is really quite unfortunate
do you worry that that's going to follow
you to whatever you do next
well I worry less about it following me
to whatever I do next and the impact
that that will have on the younger
generation of scientists
when they see when they're trying to do
their job that they're being harassed
and threatened and I'm not the only
person
I'm a person who's visible but there are
many many hard-working Physicians Public
Health officials at the local level in
cities and states throughout the country
who are being harassed because of things
that they're saying that a merely
the articulation of Public Health
principles that just doesn't make any
sense at all that a public health
official in a city or a state somewhere
in the United States is getting harassed
and even threatened because they're
doing things that are trying to save
their lives
of their fellow citizens
after all these decades in public
service what's the one thing that keeps
you up at night and what's the one thing
that gives you the most hope for the
future
well what gives me the most hope is is
is the field that I'm in because science
has
has been so extraordinary in providing
us with the tools
to uh get interventions such as vaccines
and such the classic historic example
is what has happened with covid where
you have a vaccine that has literally
saved millions and millions of lives
throughout the world
and we've gotten there because we've
made an investment in science so that's
the thing that I feel
good about that we need to continue the
support of science
the thing that keeps me up at night is
the thing that has always kept me up at
night unfortunately
that nightmare we're living through
right now is the fact that we might have
yet again another pandemic and we will
not be prepared for it if we don't learn
the lessons of what we've been through
right now
and as a final question any advice for
who comes next after you at NIH
yeah I mean my advice would be to stick
with the science and follow the science
and try as best as you can to articulate
what these scientific principles are
as as as best as you possibly can so
that people could understand that and by
all means
stay out of politics I mean I've I've
been as apolitical as anybody could
possibly be I have served seven
presidents some of whom have been
ideologically extremely different from
another one and yet we've had the
opportunity
to be able to advise them by sticking to
the science sticking to the truth and
staying out of any ideology or any
political persuasion
wonderful that's great for me thank you
for your time sir I really appreciate it
my pleasure good to be with you thank
you for having me